as well you got to see that one
you you will like that one i'm just like
studying his charisma his ability to
stay we are officially live wow david
thank you msm sapala
seven figures in the
great to be here with gerard in the
house if gerard's in the house that
means we're making progress with mafia
states of america
yeah there you go we're making progress
two hours of sleep was here four o'clock
in the morning this guy was french
pressing his own coffee right here
he tried
i asked him for a cup he's tried to sell
it to me for seven dollars
save that money
that's capitalism at its finest the fact
that he's taking a break today him and
kai are doing a merch drop okay i just
want to let you know that there will be
a surprise merch drop which is gonna get
you going crazy
i guarantee you're gonna crack up for
for a fact these guys weren't creative
so can't wait to see what it is
uh yeah you know what you may get it
you may get it signed that is true
pretty sure we can make that happen i
think we can make it happen are we
willing to give any updates on the mafia
states
the update has uh there is a few moving
parts we got a few moving parts we got
but i can tell you uh what it looks like
right now i watched an episode the other
day i'm sitting there with my dad and
i'm i'm going through one of them
and tikka and dylan are sitting there
and for 15 minutes michael and sammy are
going at it it is absolutely intense i
had to step away from the kids
and dylan says daddy isn't that sammy i
said yeah isn't that sammy the ball how
do you know well he was at the house and
i got a chance to talk to him because
sammy when they were in town for the
podcast they stopped by the house of
course dylan's memory is on a whole
different level anyway so uh we got a
lot of stuff coming on we we had
conversations with both michael and
sammy we got to get a couple things to
get comfortable with but at any moment
we may do a emergency podcast and if we
do an emergency podcast folks it's
because we're either launching it or we
have some major announcements about
mafia states of america so hang tight a
lot of stuff is coming uh together we
have to give paul to unifi a lot of
respect because he brought the whole
team together brought the whole team
together rose is a rock star eric
mario
great stuff see what's inside everybody
ever yeah you're legendary when it comes
to emergency calls emergency conference
calls merchants podcast that's true that
is true
that is true you have probably more
experience than anybody else with all
the emergency calls that we host anyways
okay so let's get into it we got a lot
of topics yeah a lot of topics
there's a couple things i want to share
with you there's a story i shared
yesterday that went viral on twitter
this teacher that failed the entire
class we'll go through that we'll take a
look at global inflation rates and
you're going to be blowing away who us
is tied with today which is pretty
insane
anna's cantor whom i texted
and uh we're trying to figure something
out to get him back on the podcast
on dates depending on when he's playing
miami i didn't see anything on the
calendar that he's playing matt miami
any soon any time soon they just played
he that's right they just played he just
called that lebron in the worst way and
over nike china and then lebron
accidentally hits another guy in the
face from detroit
isaiah stewart he calls it accidentally
azir didn't take it well he wanted to
crush the guy
but uh anyways he got suspended one game
and the guy got suspended two games
isaiah so we'll talk about that maybe a
tv host flew ten thousand miles for an
exclusive interview with adele and she
cancelled it last minute because he
didn't listen to me oops
get to know who you're interviewing
black santas are appearing in u.s disney
parks this season for the first time so
history is being made adam's story will
cover that bill maher stands up to
stands up for dave chappelle to chris
cuomo's face blast trent of kids
choosing their gender this is not crazy
stuff that makes you a bigot
and then uh buck's antonia brown uh
obtained alleged fake cover 19 vaccine
card from teammate uh we'll cover that
as well kyle rittenhouse obviously we
got to cover what happened his interview
yesterday with tucker tucker carlson
comments were made here was he coached
he was coached well uh adam uh uh didn't
like an analogy with michael jordan all
these other things that maybe we'll get
into but adam has a hard time with
analogies today adam's been a little bit
off the last few weeks but we'll help
him out we'll help him out a few weeks
army army bars vaccine refusers from
promotions and re-enlistment as deadline
approaches aoc says progressives help
wasn't wanted in virginia governor race
not a single person called us or asked
us to email mansion worries biden's
social spending agenda costs too much
new poll shows that how much the country
wants trump to run again this is an
adam's story and in beto o'rourke says
texas governor campaign won't be about
biden slams president on immigration
interesting okay so let's let's get
let's start let's start off with a very
uh simple story with adele and what
happened with adele on page four can you
imagine like you're planning this big
interview okay i'm gonna go interview
adele and you're telling your family
friends i'm flying out to interview
adele
and you're interviewing getting ready to
interview her and they ask you um have
you listened to the album and you say no
so a tv host flew ten thousand miles
from an exclusive interview with adele
only to have it canceled after he said
he hadn't listened to her new album this
is an insider's story matthew doran or
duran i lived on your end street the
host of channel 7's
the weekend sunrise show flew to london
from sydney a journey of about 10 000
miles on november 4th to interview adele
and her only album interview only the
only album interviewed with an
australian outlet during the interview
when asked by adele what he thought of
the new album duran said he hadn't
listened to it yet the singer was
offended the interview ran to completion
but sony which owns adele's music later
told channel 7 that it was withholding
the rights to the interview footage as a
result of duran's oversight several
reports said duran was subsequently
suspended by channel 7 but duran said
that he wasn't formally suspended but he
was off the air for one week so
the total package for the rights for
those interview footage which included
access to the video from oprah winfrey
one night only with adele cost the
channel cost channel seven ready seven
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
that's a channel seven seven twenty five
matt what do you think about this is it
pb you've had me interview people on
behalf of php you've had me interview bo
jackson you had emanate general uh a mad
dog mattis which you crushed by the way
both of them i appreciate that but i'm
following your model because every time
i see you do an interview i see you
consume content i see you read books i
see you have your team gives you a
package and before you're about to
interview some so just watching your
behavior before you interview somebody
it's just doing your homework
listen we're no
professional journalist but it's just
common sense if you're going to
interview something and a company is
investing
750 000 and your career could be made
because it is and you failed to do the
basic thing in terms of getting to know
the person that you're interviewing i
think that's uh
improper isn't it it was definitely
something that
i'd be professionally embarrassed about
if i wasn't prepared to interview
somebody i asked rogan i said rogan how
do you prepare for interviews he said
some of them i do some of them i don't
some of them i just go in some of them i
consume a lot of books and stuff to get
in and some of them i just go in because
i want to have a conversation with them
but
rogan didn't ask spotify to pay adele
seven hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars if a company you work for is
paying somebody that you're gonna
interview 7.25 yeah you better take care
of that i mean you you're you're i don't
know that that is irresponsible to me
it's also not like some esoteric indie
artist that like you know their agent
just shoved in front of you and you got
to like feign interest in this person
like oh yeah no
loved your uh your hit song on tick tock
there 19 year old no like you know like
i remember when bad baby was coming out
and they were trying to make her like a
uh don't you talk trash about bad babies
buddy danielle
across the table tried to catch them
outside buddy
outside and every talk show she went on
was like we love you and your mute
who is this yeah you're like yeah no
you're great and you were raised really
well yeah for sure
they all had to figure out a way to get
through it this is a dell yeah this is a
landline
hello dude i love adele so much i just i
was just trying to show tyler my first
quote unquote viral video the first
video that got me anywhere on the
internet was me with funny or die as
adele i was dressed as adele for fun
yeah yeah you know thank you thank you
man it's it's gorgeous you know i'm uh
i'm the world's most most beautiful uh
ugly system yeah what do you think about
this thing about it we gotta give
look we all know adele i don't think we
need to listen to her new album to ask
her a couple questions we know
the biggest thing she's doing she's
dating lebron's agent these days rich
paul did you know about that of course
okay that's a little bit bigger news but
this guy he came from australia sydney
australia flew to london yeah do you
familiar with what's going on with in
australia these days
yeah like this guy's just excited to get
the frick out of the house for the first
time in two years
and he gets he gets out of town out of
house and he gets packaged up resent
back to sydney to convict island i feel
bad for this guy you were all
20 hours
and it never even occurred to you to
listen to my album hello i'd be pissed
off too go get yourself some fishing
shots i needed to get out of there
if i listened to the album right yeah
just come on i mean imagine imagine
somebody comes to interview you pat they
come from all the ipad i'm a huge fan i
come to interview i'm i'm coming all the
way from australia awesome dude sits
down so
patrick what's your last name
enjoy you enjoy all your work what do
you do like what i could say you know
she could be a family yeah
by the way i want to show you so sunday
night gerard's at the house you guys
left very early like 1 30 whatever the
time was but uh we're we're having
conversations we
originally there's movies i want to get
the kids prep for we were watching
gladiator a couple scenes they probably
shouldn't watch but it is what it is
that night i made
but but i show him a clip of the rock
when he showed up to rnc republican
national convention in 2000 which i
don't know if you know this or not and
he was interviewed and a similar
situation happened as with adele so if
you can make this this is c span make it
bigger first make it bigger first so c
span you can show because it's taxpayers
money pay and c spam watch what happens
when this guy's interviewing the rock
and he has no clue the rockets and the
rock gets pissed listen
looks like steve is successful let's try
there we go just a second this is an
adele situation here on the rock head
hair let's listen in
50 pounds let's show you my naivete all
this crowd around you and i had no idea
who you are who is the rock oh it's okay
well i didn't know you either so i guess
we're kind of even uh who is the rock
the rock is the most electrifying man in
sports entertainment the wwf champion
brock is here representing the people
being the people's champion as well and
again not necessarily to try and sway
votes towards the republican candidate
or the democratic candidate for that
matter as much as he is just here to uh
you know to make sure that that the 22
million viewers the rock reaches 22
million
target version
at your birthday party i always thought
you were tongan or simone or something
at your birthday party when you told me
you were filipino i was like what are
you like two filipinos and an overcoat
or something like that you're the
biggest filipino on earth you should be
the starting center on the olympic day
well nowadays what are you lifting
nowadays but what are you hitting
nowadays are you squatting like four or
five plates what are you hitting bench
what's what's some of the numbers you're
doing right yeah uh with reps i mean i'm
doing a 415 dead list you know repping
the 315 on bench and uh you know that
you know uh i'm not doing any squats but
i do the leg press yeah so they got the
leg press machine to put both racks yeah
you can rack them i think i'm up to 15
plates on 15 racks yeah 15 45s 3 15 45
yeah 315 on the on the bench press for
long arms that's real good yeah so if
lizzo ever lays on top you can get out
that's 30 plates total
yeah yeah yeah exactly right
so so and i think what we're all
agreeing with here with the story of
adele is the fact that
also adele is classic classic of there's
no such thing as ugly you're just broke
would you say adele is the michael
jordan of something
would that totally like offend you if i
think
it's one of those things where in my
humble opinion amazing voice like the
voice itself yeah
but if i'm if i have a hundred songs to
listen to to get me in a good mood
adele's not i'm she's gonna make me cry
oh hello 25 25 it's just it's just it's
not for me well my generation but gerard
dresses up as a dell for fun apparently
so maybe that's a little more your vibe
yeah i got a great banter but i asked
him this morning what's his favorite
workout song is i'm posting something an
idea give me a workout song you were
excited he says i'm thinking like
interceptor
mario he says barbie girl
what say something about it bro
okay
i saw i saw this man sing frozen
on stage at a karaoke at a karaoke event
so gerard's very much in touch with his
feminine side yeah beautiful thing
so okay now let's go into the next story
this next story is the the teacher let's
talk about the teacher with the uh
teacher that sent that uh message out by
the way for the people that follow
snopes i don't care whether this is true
or if it's not true all i care about the
principle of the story is absolutely
fascinating i read this the other day it
says uh the teacher fails the entire
class okay teacher fails an entire class
an economic professor at a local college
made a statement that she had never
failed a single student before but had
recently failed an entire class that
class had insisted that socialism worked
and that no one else would be poor and
no one would be rich a great equalizer
the professor said okay
we will have an ex experiment in this
class on this plan all grades will be
averaged and everyone will receive the
same grade no one else will fail and no
one will receive an a substituting
grades for dollars something closer to
home and more readily understood at all
after the first test the grades were
average and everyone gotta be the
students who studied hard were upset and
the students who studied little were
happy at the second test rolled around
the students who studied little had
studied even less and the ones who had
studied hard decided they were they
wanted a free ride too so they studied
little the second test average was a d
no one was happy when the third test
rolled around the average was an f as a
test proceeded the scores never
increased as bickering blame and name
calling all result in hard feelings and
no one would study for the benefit of
anyone else to their great surprise all
field and the pro professors told them
that socialism would also be ultimately
fail when the reward is great the
efforts succeed et cetera et cetera then
he makes five she makes five points okay
these are the five points you cannot
legislate the poor into prosperity by
legislating the wealthy out of
prosperity we've heard that before
number two
what one person receives without working
for another person must work for without
receiving number three the government
cannot give to anybody anything that the
government does not first take from
someone else that's pretty tough for
some people to understand number four
you cannot multiply wealth by dividing
it and number five when half of the
people get the idea that they do not
have to work because the other half is
going to take care of them and when the
other half gets the idea that it does no
good work good to work because somebody
else is going to get what they work for
that is the beginning of the end of any
nation
do you love this professor or do you
love respect to this professor is that
the professor with the mask on or is
that just a random i think that's just
an ad because it's that sheet so the
teacher is a woman instead of a man so
what are your thoughts on this i mean
look it's one of those things where
socialism sounds great in theory right
these all these kids in the class had
like social sounds great but when put
into practice
it ain't so much fun right for
especially for the kids that are trying
hard they're trying to get good grades
and are putting in the effort so i love
that he broke it down into these five
principles
at the end of the day
i think there was a poll out there
this is maybe six months ago
and it's and half the country
young people
thought that socialism was a better no
more more than half more than more than
half of people understand 64 was it that
much like the harvard uh poll thought
that socialism was not bad was a better
um system than capitalism because they
haven't been in the workforce okay
exactly so it's one of those things
where in theory something sounds good
but when you actually practice it not as
much and they've been around so these
kids get indoctrinated by teachers and
the teachers the modern teacher and i've
got teachers in my family and i always
they feel like i'm always going after
him but this is just truth all right
every teacher i've ever met thinks that
they are smarter than they get paid for
right and that's the basis of their
ideology their college professors
specifically are resentful of the
plumber or the truck driver that makes
twice as much as they do because i'm the
smart one so obviously the system is
flawed because if if it weren't flawed
then i would be the rich one and they
would be my underling and it's like dude
you don't underst what they don't
understand and even if you've ever read
marks what people don't get is you don't
get paid for intellect you get paid for
value you can either do something that
nobody else in the world does you play
basketball all of us play basketball
none of us are in the top one percent of
it so we don't get paid to play
basketball right lebron james can get
paid billions of dollars because he's
number one our friend victor that you uh
interviewed he's a million dollar
backgammon player because he's the best
in the world at it no everybody else
plays backwards 20 some years yeah we're
doing a tour together with doubles in
vegas in january
dude he's an awesome dude his wife is
great
but but again nobody else in the world
is getting paid to play backgammon you
got to be the best in the world at it so
if you're not the best in the world at
what you want to do then you have to be
willing to do what other people aren't
willing to do nobody want wakes up in
the morning and wants to be a plumber
but there's a lot of money because
nobody wakes up in the morning and wants
to be a plumber that's what these things
that's what these lessons don't teach
man and when you're looking at a
situation like this with this what that
really wasn't socialism so much it was
this egalitarian utopia man where it's
like we're all going to be the same
together that's nonsensical i don't know
if that's true but i do know it is true
what actually did happen
in michigan and there was one in
brooklyn there was a vegan marxist
restaurant where they want to do a shoe
capitalism and they basically said eat
what you want we'll make it pay us what
you think is right men whatever you
think is right women you get you got to
pay uh 22 percent more than women do to
make up for the wages of grass
they're gone they're out of business
like it's the most predictable out of
business thing and then they they blame
capitalism for them being out of
business well we can't compete because
the prices keep rising okay
guys this is market level matt what do
you think when i think about things like
this i default to my favorite books
about which is proverbs and ecclesiastes
why because it's written by the richest
king wisest king who ever lived and
here's what he says about about this
proverbs 13 chapter 4 says the soul of
the lazy man desires and has nothing but
the soul of the diligent shall be made
rich so it depends on how you want to
attack life you want to go and attack
life and say oh i want everybody else to
help me out but i'm willing to
contribute back to society well you
should
not get back anything in return but if
you want to contribute to that you want
to be diligent you're up you're getting
up you're doing your part and uh that's
probably one of the hardest things
because
you said mention you mentioned earlier
that what's the biggest platform today
the people who are lazy people want to
complain that that's no that's who's got
the biggest platform the biggest pic
i had the greatest compliment the other
day on my youtube channel at 7 30 squad
somebody says you mr wanted to be junior
valuetainment
what was that supposed to be you guys
are rich because you have no college
degree so why are you why are you
getting mad at us yeah why are you
getting mad at us let me let me ask you
something on that because i i don't
think we throw around this word lazy i
don't think they're lazy i just don't
think they don't want to do
what they anything they don't desire
doing like they'll yeah nobody does
that's the difference they don't want to
do i feel like is the difference i don't
know if that's instagram i don't know
let me let me ask you a question let me
ask you guys let me ask you guys a
question so here's a question for you
okay
uh
what will make you vote for
biden okay what will make you vote for
biden what has to be and for you
the question is what will make you vote
for trump okay hear me out where i'm
going here so just think about for
whoever that voted against biden or
whoever that voted against trump you got
to ask the question at what level will
you vote for
the opposition okay so for me if you
look at aoc here's how aoc works there's
a part i relate to aoc this is why i
relate to eoc
aoc do you think she supports what biden
is doing right now no she's actively
we're going to talk about that here in a
minute it's absolutely berserk she's not
happy with biden right the aoc the ilhan
omar all those guys during the verse
when it comes down to voting who's she
going to vote for trump or she's going
to vote for by no no okay so now watch
this year watch us here for me okay
i don't like uh
half the stuff that happens where the
divisiveness and constant creating new
enemies that maybe trump takes the route
and he's constantly going after him
right
but when it comes down to it i'm gonna
vote for whoever is for lower taxes low
regulation
eliminating censorship for me so so
that's where it goes to okay here's what
i'm gonna go as a registered independent
for the last ten years this is where i'm
going i'm a libertarian that we've not
yet seen a solid joj jorgensen when i
sat down with ron paul and we did the
interview and i were there together and
i think it was in houston when we did
the interview
it was incredible by the time you're
done you're like this guy makes a lot of
sense but the question is at what point
will somebody in your party come out
were you gonna say i'm voting for the
person you would least vote for in this
instance it's biden and trump i'm going
to go with you first so who needs to be
on your side of the aisle which is let's
just say
the left the center left who needs to be
on your side of the aisle we're going to
say you know what screw it um
i'm not going to vote for anybody on the
left i'm going to go vote for trump
would anybody make you vote for him
repeat you're saying okay would anybody
be able to convince me let's just say no
no let's just say the the person that's
running on your side is
beto it's
mcconaughey it's aoc it's
a mansion it's whoever who would need to
be the nominee on the left for you to
say i'm sitting this one out i'm
actually going to vote for trump on this
one
see
maybe the bigger question is would i
vote for a republican no no this
specific because i would i would vote
for republicans but this this but not a
trump so this specific question i'm
asking you
like for them if i say clinton they're
gonna say yeah no problem voting for
bill clinton to this specific example it
is biden and it is trump the reason why
i'm using this example as a following
reason
is biden's probably the least democratic
president republicans would want okay
probably worse than carter okay but many
republicans were okay with uh uh bill
clinton so and on the democratic side
trump is probably the least candidate
you would want on the opposite side
maybe you would be comfortable with a
reagan hypothetically right versus a
trump what i'm asking is who needs to be
on your side of the aisle to say
i think it's crossed the line i'm
probably going to go vote for trump who
would it be
you're saying running against trump pose
the question specifically i've asked
four times
i've asked this thing four times did you
get my question or no there's literally
nobody that you would detest so much on
the democratic side that would make you
be like nah you know what trump said
like anyone elon omar was no no no i
don't know anything anything on the 10
left so who would make you say i'm going
to vote i'm actually going to support
trump if the candidate was is was as
equally as divisive as trump if
my whole thing is
we all like look at us we can all get
along we can all have dinner we can all
have lunch we can all get along we're
america okay he's a marine he's a
talented guy he's a businessman i mean
like we we all have like christian men
of the club what i'm saying a jewish a
christian like
we're not as divided as the media or
politics want us to i don't disagree
like what we need in this country is
someone who's going to go back to the
question
can we all just sit down and have a
basic
niceness towards each other let me know
trump doesn't doesn't bring that out of
the question at all for the fifth time
this is where the audience gets upset
sometimes because you don't answer
questions no matter what you say you're
not going to convince me to vote for
[ __ ] trump so
whatever by the way whatever
you wanted
by the way i'm not going to say you got
it
fyi that's when you lose people brother
that's when you lose people because i'm
not willing
this is where your argument loses
because you lose credibility because i'm
not willing to succumb to trump you ask
me a question and you say a guy like an
alex jones is the face of the right and
i got and biden on the other side i'm
probably going to say i have no clue
what this guy's going to do i'm going to
have to consider that vote but to you
it's hard to have logic to say here's
what would make me say i'm going to go
this way because even right now like
give you an idea kodak blew the other
day tweets out i don't know if you guys
saw kodak blues kodak black kodak black
kodak blue kodak black says come down
here pompano yeah he just tweets out the
other day did you see the tweet here's
what kodak said the other day he said
uh uh uh uh it's not coming out come on
kai oh
sorry about it okay kodak black sends a
tweet and he says you guys wanna it's
not working for you you gotta be kidding
me it's just the basics
how much of your decision-making process
goes with uh percentage-wise goes with
voting for policy versus the person i'm
just curious that's exactly where my
next question was going
the
i mean i think it's 50-50 i mean maybe
even more persona than policy more
people i don't i don't know how much
does policy
how many people actually get down and
dirty into people's policies i think
people are what their platform is yeah i
think most people are one issue voter or
two-issue voter and they they what's
your what's your number one issue
see i don't have family i don't have
kids so i'm not as issue oriented i
so what what what were you gonna change
your the the name of your uh twitter
handle to be or a centrist
or a synergist
synergist yeah that's what this country
needs it's so that's not the question
though but that's the point but that's
not the question though what this is the
guy that's saying we need a synergist
that's what i'm saying okay the story is
not the way we keep doubling down on
trump doubling down trump imagine if we
had trump president again let me imagine
we don't have trump president again we
have someone that actually that the
entire country actually likes whether
it's in the left or right then there
can't be a reasonable conversation with
you why can't there be a reason because
i just asked you a reasonable question
and you can't give a reason it's been
eight minutes i'm moving the story i'm
gonna go to you so who needs to be on
your side for you to say i would
consider biden uh biden actually was
probably my my uh
third or fourth choice out of the
democratic primary i'm much happier that
biden got in i thought that for sure
that they were going to try to shove
kamala harris down her throat
they still made it's not too late it's
not too late um you know as far as look
i don't like coercion
when when you get into the democratic
party and you get into the coercive
nature of what they are anybody who
increases wants you like what what aoc
what we talked about we talked about
this morning aoc is going after biden
for not being a dictator saying he has
unilateral powers to to uh do universal
health care to eliminate student debt to
to base she wants the president united
states with the stroke of his pen
to completely and totally nationalize
executive order executive order
executive order and not just little
things yeah she wants essentially the
government through one stroke of the man
of one person's pen to nationalize
entire verticals of our of our
government and our economy the fact that
she's saying that and she's lamenting
the fact that he won't be a dictator
terrifies me because they show their
face so who would need to be on the
right for you to say i remember i didn't
vote for trump the first time i get that
that's why i'm asking you so for you who
is too far right
i would have voted for tulsi gabbard in
a heartbeat i would have voted for
uh back in the day remember joe
lieberman i liked joe lieberman back in
the interesting thing like joe lieberman
i thought bill clinton was a really
really when you talked about chris
christie i when i was when i was with
christy
he was a synergist and cory booker
wasn't this far left socialist cory
booker and chris christie work like this
and they really did an unbelievable job
for the city of newark then they got on
a national scale and they had to go to
the extremes when i was younger right
and you guys are you know a little older
than me you guys remember the way to win
was to work towards the center now the
way to win seems to be to work towards
the extremes they are terrified of their
extremes i think it's because there's no
money anywhere else only the crazy and
the greedy donate money guys normal
everyday working americans they're not
donating their time they're not out
there volunteering they're not out there
marching lunatics are lunatics are the
ones that are filling the streets all
right so that's where the political you
can't run a campaign without volunteers
and money and they have to go to the
extremes to get this and i think that's
what's pulling off you know what i like
about van jones let me tell you what i
like about van jones maybe that could be
something for as an inspiration for
our buddy here okay
this is i'm a van jones fan and van
jones was a communist card holding guy
years ago when he first was
chosen to be part of
obama's what do you call it uh
uh administration within a week they
have to get him to be gone because the
guy was a former communist he supported
some of the principles of communism so
you have to resign well
do you remember when uh trump went out
there and he did what he did with a
prison uh reform and it was something
that nobody had ever done and he came in
and he fixed it and he it was just
absolutely berserk and
uh uh tr and van jones if you guys don't
remember this can you click on van jones
trump prison reform picture wasn't it
okay kardashian somehow information
if she was in a big way but but this is
not even a kim's story this is about a
van jones who hates trump
okay who hates trump if you go to images
goes
images go to images and type in the
picture right there go the one to the
left the one to the left right there
can you click on it okay uh see if we
can make that bigger
all right see if you go a little closer
go a little closer
uh we can't play that can we so go back
and go to the uh uh go back and see if
we can find another picture
um
okay click on any one of those on the
bottom right there to uh to the right
to the right yeah go click on that one
let's just say sit down okay do you see
who's standing behind that lady with the
red jacket on who is that van jones who
is he he's a hardcore democrat you know
but he went to that and you know what he
did on cnn that that pissed off cuomo
and everybody else he started crying
he started crying he says because this
is the first time i've seen a president
be able to do something with prison
reform you know what that's called
that's called the synergist a synergist
is not somebody that no matter what the
guy cannot do anything right that's not
a synergist so if you're talking about
you wanting to be a synergist van jones
to me who him and i disagree on 80
percent of things politically i respect
the [ __ ] out of this position here this
is what we need fyi principle when it's
it's when i ask a question and here's
what's said when i ask a question so
people ask me and they'll say why do you
interview so many communists you know
how many people i've lost because i
interview communists do you know how
many people go read the comment section
it's too bad though if any any of the
communists i know you see what they say
at the bottom i say i'm actually trying
to see where we agree
where do we agree i want to understand
you to get an idea of where we agree and
then from that you say okay okay i sat
down with alex jones on 9 11 you and i
were there that interview was almost
done with you remember when he started
biting the apple we thought it's going
to be done when he's going to walk off
the set yeah but we had the conversation
and what was the conversation about you
pressed the hell out of it i pressed the
hell out of him and he was unhappy about
it so it wasn't like well hey alex so
tell me what a fantastic job you you're
pissing a lot of people off on the other
side this is so cool bro the guy wanted
to leave he was not happy with us no he
he his handler was like
yeah his hand
let me ask you a question
at any point that you're interviewing
these people do you say
that's a good point actually one million
percent okay so you've you've one
million percent you've said hey good
point two communists okay exactly yes so
so go with me now here so on individual
points you said okay check for the karl
marx
but at any point no matter how many
points this guy's made is there any
chance that you're going to believe in
communism and socialism did you just
hear money the answer is no right but
did you just see what you're doing do
you see what you're doing these two
analogies have nothing to do with each
other i didn't make an analogy and i'm
asking you a question you're making a
point right without having answered the
question yet so for you the question
that was asked on your end you can't
answer because to you
i see i see what you did there i see
what you did there you're i was trying
to make a vowel i don't know in your
eyes in your eyes a man can't do
anything right that's not pat that's not
what i said wait a minute that's not
what i said i asked you what i said
specifically was questions i will give
trump credit on certain things i like
what he did in the middle east i asked
him i like what he did on deregulation
but that doesn't mean i'm going to be a
trump fan or vote for him do you
actually like you said you wouldn't
you've agreed with certain socialist
points
because i see what you did there and i
was good that was a good tactic did what
there explained to me what did you like
i tried to make the same analogy that
you made for me and and in my mind do
you realize the real analogy the we've
asked you six times the same question
okay so i'll be very surprised either
you say either you answer to have
credibility to get a response from me
yes sir or you don't if you don't answer
you have no credibility here's my
discussion here's that simple are there
things that trump has done well yes
that's the question though so let's skip
it if you don't want to answer the
question i wouldn't vote for trump i
said it a million dollars not the
question the question is who on your
side of the aisle needs to represent for
you to say i would actually entertain an
oppose this is a regular conversation
you're saying how bad does the
democratic candidate have to be seven
times the same question basically would
you vote for every time omar or donald
trump let me ask you i vote for joe
jorgensen
serious question how much of that is
social equity your you know your friends
your family the people that you
associate with god forbid they ever
found out i don't give two shits you
know
seriously uh honestly clearly i don't
give a [ __ ] about what you don't know
what people think how i vote i don't
care
you're half my friend's circle half my
friends think that i'm a
a uh i actually i'm not a
guy because i'm on this channel let me i
have to people think i'm a communist uh
i don't give a [ __ ] there's a person
i'll explain why i asked that question
it wasn't an accusation it's a serious
question it's fine there's a person very
very close to me that i absolutely love
who staunch staunch far left
basically her whole life okay
came up through academia and made her
career in it and over the course of the
last 20 months
she's now
moving in a direction i actually got a
text from her she was like she was like
uh you've been right about a lot of
things that pains me to say that and i'm
like well one more time
i got a screenshot that now she can't
be vocal about what she believes to be
true that's the hardest part
she believes she'll be ostracized in her
community her her friends will ostracize
her she's seen cancer culture up close
and personal she is literally a prisoner
of and what's her community though
uh her community is academics okay so
she's in the liberal northeast academic
community i'm assuming correct yeah when
you insulate yourself into a bubble
that's what happens whether you're on
the left or the right
if you're
see this is where i gotta disagree it
might even be worse than the left i
gotta yeah i gotta disagree because my
experience has been especially in the
entertainment industry
people on the right will have no problem
hanging out with people on the left they
have no problem hiring people on the
left they have they have no problem
being disagreed with and those those
those instances whereas
the the more progressive quote unquote
the situation is the the job site is or
the environment is they tolerate no
blasphemy yeah but that's a recent thing
bro nobody wouldn't hire you
ten years ago because you liked george w
bush i hear you it would have been
irrelevant because of trump what's
interesting about that is that i
actually didn't like george bush i
didn't like dick cheney and now dick and
liz cheney are pro-biden now all of a
sudden the progressives are on the side
of the warhawk republicans it's the
establishment
it's a weird situation but you say it's
it's a recent thing that's why we're
talking about it because this this is
not passing the smell test this is not
an okay thing and nobody's talking about
do me a favor do me a favor pull up
something here pull up something here
and we're gonna go off the store and go
to the next story pull up power versus
force
type in power versus force okay
and then click on images click on images
top left
and then click on uh the one with a bun
click on that right there that's fine
make that bigger okay make that bigger
see if you can make click on it again
hopefully it can get okay fantastic so
so adam this this is the challenge in
america today okay
this book was written by david r hawkins
i don't know how many years ago i read
this 20 years ago so it's got it's been
around for a while maybe 18 years ago
something like that so he talks about
when
we go from power
force to power okay and force is
obviously not a good thing to persuade
people your power you can persuade
people lowest level of influence is
shame anytime you're coming from a place
of shame you have no
ability to persuade you don't have any
power no you can't do nothing you're
helpless right then it's guilt you feel
guilty i feel guilty about what i did to
her i feel guilty about what i did then
it's apathy okay then it's grief then
it's fear you have a lot of anxiety but
fear is still better than grief apathy
guilt and shame then there's desire so
constant sex constant drugs constant
gambling drinking then it's anger anger
is still better than fear because at
least you're expressing yourself to
people right
then you got pride which is where many
people on the certain sides that don't
want to politically sit and agree with
anybody you get stuck at this level
pride
first level of freedom and leadership is
courage having the courage to entertain
what it would look like maybe i'm not
right maybe i'm willing to entertain
then it's neutrality where let's have a
neutral conversation then it's
willingness i'm willing to be
entertained i'm willing to make this
work i'm willing to have a relationship
with gerard i'm willing for us to like
we'll have a conversation together we're
willing you're willing i'm willing we
can make this thing go places but if
you're not willing and i'm willing
there's no way this thing can work right
then there's acceptance then level 400
is what reason what is reason
reason is what we try to do on this
podcast we try to reason reason is when
i interview somebody and we like to
reason with each other we sit down we
have a conversation favorite
conversations in the world are people
that are willing to reason with you
after the reason is love which we love
you so that's the foundation of it then
it's joy peace enlightenment which will
never reach that level of enlightenment
just to kind of give you a score they
score people einstein score like a 4.99
okay
gandhi and them they'll put them at a
different level they got mother teresa
is bliss slash slight enlightenment
jesus is obviously a thousand he scores
it all that in that level have you done
a score
have i done my score yeah i've done my
score and robert o'rourke did my score
before i did my score he came up to me
the other day says do you know what your
score is i'm like i don't know what my
score how did you do your score anyways
there's a way of doing it the point
isn't about where i'm at or where you're
at where anybody's at i think the
challenge is if we're going to make
progress we have to have the courage
to be neutral and willing to accept
certain things we're wrong and others
and then find a way to reason and if we
can figure out a way to love
well then we can make some progress
though
how do you get people to go from
to shift from force into power it is the
first stage there because there's a lot
of pride is there a question you asked
how do you draw them out you can't do so
so you can so i can get this message
sure and then he gerard like somebody
gave me this message because i was i was
in a place of if you look at me here
uh [ __ ] i was probably fear desire anger
pride
that's majority of my life because i've
just understood this concept like 20
years because i'm 43
probably at 25 26 i'm still in
fear can i really do this i'm still in
desire man i'm still having girls on the
side i'm still partying hardcore anger i
had a temper horrible i still got a
temper but it's more tame than i can
control it then it's pride so the first
time this was presented to me i didn't
want to you know i'm like i don't know
if this totally makes sense what are you
talking about i'm somebody that's and
then i realize no you're not
you're not willing you're you're not
neutral you only talk to the people that
you agree with you're not accepting
you're not this you're not that right
you're not coming from that place but
when we were off camera and i want to
change the topic because we got a lot of
things i want the audience to hear other
topics as well when we were off camera
we talked about kyle rittenhouse sure
right
and then uh you and tyler i think what
comment did you make about kyle
yesterday on tucker you said he's a good
kid he's a he's a kid that you would
find in your typical suburban chicago
neighborhood yeah and and tyler what did
you say you said something about the guy
he came off as a good kid you know he
worked hard he worked as a janitor
supporters family he was a lifeguard he
was a medic and he was just completely
lamb bad it's like he's a completely
different kid than what the media sure
and then we talk about blm and you know
how he supports blm but he says i don't
support the writing or i don't know
sure i support a movement great
fantastic and then the conversation was
what well he was coached sure because he
was coached to do something like this
right and then another interview on the
tucker he was coach which by the way do
we all agree that he was coached one
million percent of his coach there's no
question he wasn't coaching of course he
was coaching
but
no matter how much he coaches me
how long will it take you to coach me
to beat you in mma if we go and grapple
how long you're looking in pretty good
shape i know you're back what i'm trying
to say to you is what i'm trying it's
going to take more than a day or two
it's going to take probably a few years
right because that's been your world
no matter how much he coaches me or your
friend coaches me how much is it going
to take me for me to go to a stand-up
comedy and get a 60-minute special how
long is it going to take me five 10
years it's going to take a while right
so so no matter how much you press this
power versus force concept to people
they're not going to it's not going to
be a day or two or it took me three five
years to fully understand what i was
dealing with with this i know you i know
you want to move on but i have one
question on that because i i understand
that on on an individual level and it's
a really great way to be introspective
and see where you're at
now on a collective level
we just saw for 20 months here fear is
is an incredibly powerful tool for
control
you get people to feel afraid if you
could control their media's business
model yeah i mean they're three c's
right baby change conflict controversy
they made people afraid of the air man
there's people still right now i was
just in st louis there's people afraid
of the air yeah walking around outside
muzzled up yeah like yep like
if you can control them where they see
every human being that they encounter as
a potential threat yeah you you can do
anything you want with those people now
now you're the savior
hey yep this is scary world
give me come with me yeah i'll help you
i'll save you it's just gonna cost you
all your money and your freedom yeah
i'll protect you i'm the good guy
right i got the jab all right
whatever whatever whatever you need
maybe i know i need a fourth one i need
a fifth one
but fear
the the lowest level of that
force versus power
just
put the world on pause for two years
they took the whole world over
for two years by making people afraid
okay so how do you how do you process
that from an individual level to a
collective level yeah first of all the
fear sharpens listening right when
people are afraid people listen so they
have to scare the hell out of you for
you to watch the news if they don't
scare the hell out of you they're not
going to watch the news so
you you got to figure out a way to
increase the identity of people and like
for example running the company when we
started off the company a php insurance
company the first thing i said is save
in america by bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to american
families right there's two things you
can train people on willpower skills
skill is how to sell will is you can do
it right
typically most people think it's skill
set that's very necessary willpower is
just as necessary matter of fact
slightly more necessary than skill
because willpower may will make you
figure out a way to learn the skill
you're going to figure out the skill
right okay so yes if all of you have a
skill and no willpower you're just lazy
rely on yourself one percentage rely on
your skills
so for example yesterday we're doing the
whole giveaway zach parker a shout out
to him he came out with this idea about
us
i'm saying let's give some stuff away so
he produces the website everybody's
applying for us to give away sport folks
we're calling a bunch of people
unfortunately we're trying to facetime
so some of the people that have drawn uh
what do you call it android we can't
facetime all right so we called only
apple we have to check the numbers first
believe it or not anyways so we call
this one lady apple stock goes up
we call this one a husband husband
nominates wife and says my wife lost her
job during covid
wouldn't take any government assistance
wouldn't even apply to get any money
nothing she didn't take a single penny
from the government during covet she
found ways to get a job two or three
jobs i just want to figure out and make
my wife's experience better for holidays
anything you can do please do so i call
her once twice three times she ain't
picking up fourth time she picks up
facetime and she says who are you i
don't recognize you her husband follows
by me she does not i said your husband
thinks the world of you okay and he told
me that during this 18 months while
everybody else was taking a stimulus you
didn't do it you figured out a way to
get two or three jobs to make money for
the family and he thinks you're the hero
of the family everybody leaned on you
and i wanted to find a way to make your
holiday season a better season for you i
said what can i do for you i said do you
mind if i send you to the spa best spa
local manicure pedicure massage the
whole nap for a full day we treat you
she says no i don't want you to do that
and he said he's not gonna she's not
gonna take anything from you so i'm like
okay then is there any way i can make it
better she says yes one way i said
what's that
she's too
so powerful story she says my husband
wants a toolbox
still think about other people my
husband wants a toolbox
and it's 600 bucks i don't have the
money for it
instead of sending me to the spa
please get him the toolbox if you can do
that that would make my christmas
we're sitting there freaking i'm like
selfless so i say you know what i said
forget about it
you ever been to a spa before never in
my life she's probably in her 30s you
know mid 30s early 30s i said never in
your life no i said how about we send
you to the spa and how about we also get
the toolbox for your husband
she breaks down crying like you wouldn't
believe me right to me i said you don't
know how much of a hero you are to me
yeah i said we need more people like you
here's a person that's stubborn enough
to say i'm not going to take the free
money give it to somebody
[Music]
as the flipping hero yeah it's always
you don't have our life we understand
how hard life is this is why we should
send you more checks this is why we
should send you three trillion dollars
what eight hundred dollars you deserve
two thousand dollars a month i i can't
stand that because it's decreasing the
identity of people that's what's hurting
us i'll tell you what that's you're 100
right that's really good but i'll tell
you that guy he was so upset that he
nominated her because he was like just
chilling and she's like if i'm gonna be
out here doing two three jobs i'm gonna
get this [ __ ] at two box and he's got
a lot of time around the house to fix
all this [ __ ]
honey honey dude anyway
listen since we took us 25 minutes on
this story we still didn't get an answer
let's move on to the next one here all
right let's go to the next one black
santas are appearing in u.s disney parks
this season for the first time this is a
page five story uh without an official
statement or fanfare u.s disney parks
are including black santa claus and
christmas celebrations this year for the
first time in the company 66-year team
history at both disneyland in anaheim
and
lake buena vista florida a black santa
has been spotted at certain meet and
greets and at after hour christmas
parties a disney spokesperson told cnn
that santa claus is represented in
various ways in local and regional
communities and around the world and in
that spirit santa claus will be
reflected with diversity surrounding
communities at both disneyland resort
and walt disney world resort what's your
what's your thoughts on this uh yeah i'm
a chicago guy yeah it's uh around my
neighborhood in chicago humboldt park
west side of chicago berwin soros
technique we always have black santas we
have puerto rican santas we have mexican
santa so
i'm not a coast kid you know i didn't go
to disneyland or disney world growing up
so
my first time going to those parks was
when i was in the military station in
southern california went up to
disneyland i actually got recruited into
the insurance industry out of anaheim
yeah but uh you know very good i can't
believe it took this long however for
for dizziness to actually put something
like this together my sister who was a
dance my sister was a dancer she uh she
ballet jazz that she worked for for
disney
and uh i always was you know big brother
type stuff and so she was a snowflake
during the nutcracker type of dance
people asked me hey which one's your
sister which one's your sister she's one
of the snowflakes right yeah my sister's
the dirty snowflake
big brother you were in the military
your sister was a ballet dancer that's
right that must have been fun oh yeah
all the time
that was a protective i was the
protector big brother oh yeah and i come
to find out the most men in the dancing
business you know i didn't have to worry
about it oh yeah
i was thinking more like you're i was
thinking more like your platoon mates
man everyone always wanted to go to the
ballet that's it
bro when the internet first came out i
said hey cool yeah which was older
brother phil yeah i had my first
modeling gig awesome hey maurice get
over here with this computer's dial up
so started you know slowing yeah yeah
come to finish his modeling
a sports bra this goes to what we were
talking about i destroyed i destroyed
the miners
i had a field day with my marines at the
time dude we just talked about this i
left the sidebar away
what what do you do what do you do if
this is a good question here we go
because dylan uh dylan and uh you know
patrick you have to worry about this
stuff yes
so we i i'm entering an age now where my
buddy has has daughters that are that
are now grown women forget about all
right freshman in college and stuff like
that and they're posting things that are
just like oh my god little little
justine what this is i don't know what
to do do you like these they're posting
them they post the thirst don't you dare
they like all your stuff are you
supposed to like their stuff back no
they'll find out
matsupala's sister posts something for
clout
you want to give her the clout
if i double tap on instagram my am i
helping or hurting now
here's the problem buddy this is why how
i stay away from all this nonsense i
don't follow anybody's wives i don't
follow anybody's young daughter it's not
happening even if they follow you zero
social equity i don't give a [ __ ]
there's i like very rarely will i follow
someone's i don't need the drama why'd
you double tap on my wife my girlfriend
my daughter like
i don't follow i'm out i i'm in the
minority here i think you don't you
follow everybody's wife you're double
tapping wives
you gotta show support if they didn't
want people to see it they wouldn't post
it if they don't if there's a double
standard that was allowed to exist to be
right this subject matter right
yeah double tap everybody else except my
sister anyway what are your thoughts on
santa
black background you know maybe
maybe even a jewish santa every once in
a while sprinkle it i think it's great i
think we we've had dude the only thing
we've had in our household is the middle
eastern standard
do i to me santa claus is from iran you
know or syrian armenians so you just
that you only have to have a certain
amount of qualifications yeah you need
to be fat and you need to be jolly
if you're not eating well yeah you don't
have to have a shitty attitude but this
is a santa for years nobody is not free
this is a cnn story okay to me to be
honest with you i don't even know why
this is a story this is not a big deal
that's what it should be what bothers me
is the fact that they want to they want
a parade for it it's like okay you got
black santa yeah all right but it's like
we took the we went ahead and made black
if you want a solid santa with a lot of
facial hair go to glendale california
you're gonna find a lot of armenians
that are qualified to be santas there's
guys armenian food is not good for you
okay
it's oily food you're going to get fat
and they got the sickest beers
but there's one thing about armenian
santas they have a temper so if you get
on your ass for too much they're going
to tell you to get the hell out of here
okay i'm not american santa this is
middle eastern center standards are
slightly different anyways okay let's
continue let's go to the buccaneers
antonio brown obtained alleged fake
covet 19
vaccine card from teammates page eight
uh so he plays for the box okay if you
don't know who this guy is antonio brown
is uh at one point i think he was the
fastest guy in the nfl it was a stealer
on thursday tampa bay times
report claimed that tampa bay buccaneer
star wide receiver antoni brown used a
fake over 19 vaccination car to get
around certain nfl health and safety
protocols without having to receive one
of the safe and available coronavirus
vaccines i like the way they said one of
the safe and available chrono vaccine
shots the nfl and its reviewers uh uh
the matter but the overall situation
took a different turn friday when espn's
gina lane reported ruiz says brown
obtained the alleged fake vaccination
card from a buccaneer's teammate he got
them from another player who was selling
them rui said that player came over to
the house multiple times he had to get
another uh a copy of brown's
girlfriend's vaccine card because they
got her birthday wrong on the first one
faking or doctoring a covenant
vaccination card is a federal criminal
offense and also violates the nfl's
personal conduct policy meaning brown
could be fined or suspended if the
league proves of this uh ultimately
believes ruiz's claims gerard thoughts
listen you take somebody that's
completely and totally healthy and tell
them that they can't work unless they
inject themselves with something that
they don't want to inject themselves
you're going to create a black market
all right this is this is after this is
right on the heels of aaron rodgers all
right where they tried to skewer aaron
rodgers for for his decision why does
the elite media why does the the let's
just call it what it is why why when i
was in in st louis all right
i posted all about it if people follow
me i posted all about it on and i went
on this whole rant about every place was
closed shut down all right place was hit
hit hard by covid and it was shut down
and the places that weren't shut down
all right there was one place called
gramophone it's like the only place that
was open and in order to get in for me
to get dinner all right it's a
sandwich and beer shop i had to show a
negative kova test within the last 72
hours or a vax car to go inside and eat
a sandwich and i'm out there and the guy
the bouncer who's sitting outside with a
mask on outside i'm like bro
i'm going to go inside and i'm going to
have a sandwich no one's sitting in
there no one's around me
you you need me to prove
just this i was like what if i have
herpes i'm going to drink out of this
glass and then somebody else is going to
drink out of the glass that i'm going to
drink out of shouldn't i show a negative
test from that
the old herpes
should have not shouldn't you guys prove
to me shouldn't i be able to see that
you guys are cleaning things effectively
does this so anyway i get into this
whole thing with this guy obviously
because you know i had to make a scene
about it i'm just sitting here like wait
a minute man
every place is closed every place is
closed here's one guy trying to give you
business and you're saying no
no you you can't come in because
you're not obeying us has nothing to do
with health what do you think is going
to happen to antonio brom that's what
what do you think is nothing too brown
he's going to get suspended and fine
well i think so because the nfl needs to
make an example of somebody there's
gonna be a fall guy just like there's a
drug test he's an easy guy to do it too
by the way yeah and if you think about
it antonio brown is an easy guy it's not
like it's mahomes or it's brady you can
do it to this guy they didn't suspend
rogers so they i don't think they can
suspend antonio brown
rogers said what roger said he had taken
a vaccine
immunization but he did not go so far as
the fake passport yeah that's the
differentiator just so you know guys
i've gotten arrested for having a fake
vaccination card just so you know that
so can you google uh a arrested fake
vaccination card i remember a father and
a son asian picture came about like six
months ago where these guys got arrested
for having a fake vaccination card
illinois woman arrested over a modern
vaccine card yeah new york man charged
with felony for faking vaccine card yeah
this is this is not like it's a uh
seven year in prison oh hang on go back
to it go back to it watch this
new york man charged with felony could
face seven years in prison after being
accused of faking a coven 19 vaccine
this pisses me off
what i'm what i'm trying to say to you
is what i'm trying to say to you
your answer is what they should do to
him that's not my question my question
is what do you think the nfl goedel will
be forced to do to brown he's if phil's
going to cave and again they got to make
a fall guy because they got to set up
like a set of presidents for the rest of
the league just like they do the drug
policy you pop test for a banned
substance and that kid whoever is
playing is gone for the year i think
it's going to happen to eb he's been in
and out of the news teams for a handful
of years now i'm more concerned about
his quote unquote teammate who was
selling them as a side hustle
what kind of guy out there is on the
teammate be like look you went on fake
it's like
focus on playing blocking and tackling
you you don't think that's happening all
over the other day
i have a good friend of mine that shall
remain nameless
that has a fake vax card yeah this
person had covet didn't want he's
healthy didn't want to get the vacs
travels sometimes internationally
has a fake vax card and this is not
a right winger to say the least he just
wants to be able to do his thing so
you brought up the word black market and
that's exactly what's going on here
anytime that there's rules and
regulations that you don't agree with
you're going to try to skirt the issues
it's just crazy and that's what's going
on here it's just crazy as a felony that
pisses me off because you have a
fellaini on your record you can't get a
job but you can get licensed not think
about this think about this okay
can you sue them where's accountability
lie right now can you sue them if they
get sick if you get sick can you sue
them of course not you can't no then
fire the the fda who's supposed to be
working on our behalf
just
asked a federal court
to withhold the the the fo the foi the
the uh what is it um freedom of
information act 55
until we know whether they knew it would
make us sick yeah with weeks 55 years
ago all we've been told is trust the
science trust the science but you can't
read the science until
2075. you know she has made it also a uh
illegal so where's accountability
accountability is shut up and do what
you're told shut up and do what you're
told by the way
gerard said that so quickly can you pull
up that story
because
uh that's uh
you're coming out with a product that we
cannot sue here you go this is the this
is the story a vaccine vaccine is an
injury attorney fd asked judge to grant
it until you're 2000 let me read this
guys fda asks judge to grant it until
year 2076 to release pfizer vaccine data
attorney 3 published an update on his
case against the fda and he wrote the
fda has asked a federal judge to make
the public wait until the year 2076 to
disclose all of the data information it
relied upon to license pfizer covet 19
vaccine this is not a typo it wants 55
years to produce this information to the
public so let's get this straight the
federal government shields pfizer from
liability gives it billions of dollars
makes americans take its product but
won't let you see the data supporting
this product safety and efficiency why
does the government who does the
government work for so this is a very
big problem huge to have something like
this setting up for themselves yeah
2076 that's what 50
55 years from now insane to be able to
do that so will anything happen to him
will anything happen antonio brown
yes
well he didn't play last night on moneta
football i don't know if he's injured
right now or if he's suspended currently
but he didn't play last night on monday
night football i don't know
what the ramifications do you think the
nfl is gonna go as far as suspending him
from the season no okay do you think
this is gonna be like a one game or two
gamer type of suspension okay what do
you think is gonna happen to the guy
that's slanging him if they can do an
investigation that guy's gotta have to
answer some serious questions okay so
you think how many other people did he
sell them to sure what kind of side
hustle is he operating let me let me ask
you this question let me ask you a
slippery slope here what they do if the
nfl finds out
and this guy comes out and says i'm
selling vaccination card says just so
you know there's 30 other guys that's
selling it on every single team not on
my team
on every team rampant someone selling
because because of a guy selling it on
tampa bay who's the poster child of the
he's the nfl of that team which means
you don't think tom knew this so tom
knows this so i think
i mean we can't assume that he listens
if you've read tv also if it's odds if
we're playing the game of odds odds are
a captain's gonna know that this is
taking place if this is taking place
roger goodell's probably gonna want the
story to go away and not make a bigger
deal about it because he knows a brady
in the super bowl gets more eyeballs
than a you know somebody else in the
super bowl so let's just address the
elephant in a room too if aaron rodgers
didn't get suspended and antonio brown
does every black person in america skip
and shannon is going to go nuts for an
entire we just he didn't lie about
having a vaccine guard though he
it's it
half the world still thinks kyle
rittenhouse killed three black guys so
there's you know he's a white
supremacist come on man yeah yeah i mean
you know we live in a world where when
uh that that that poor bastard drove
through not the the crazy bastard drove
through
yeah
uh drove through wisconsin half the
people were waiting to see whether the
driver was white or black to see how to
respond this is just the reality of the
situation now it's not right it disgusts
me to the core of my freaking being i
hate everything about this where we have
to view everything through the lens of
this black and white i got to tell you
yesterday a guy
was asking me a question he says hey pat
can you can you go on twitter please my
account and he says can you tell me what
you don't like about capitalism tell me
what you don't like because you're so
much about capitalism can you say
something you don't like about capitals
right that's a fair question so i
responded back to the guy and i tweeted
and i actually answered them here's what
i said okay my answer was keep going
down keep going down keep going down
keep going down down down there it is
okay click on that tweet because there's
a part two and a part three click on the
top no no not
tyler we gotta teach you what to click
on right there that's right there okay
good all right so
i said he asked me a question i'm a big
valuetainer from india and i have a
question if there's just one thing you
would change about capitalism what would
it be i said this is what i would change
about capitalism number one eliminate
all lobbyists and special interest group
this is how big companies like pfizer
bully small companies capitalism by
itself is good until politicians who
need campaign money to get re-elected
get desperate they're often for sale
right number two is create a flat text
that puts it right in the same camp et
cetera et cetera stay on the first one
right there stay right there that's
cronyism that's not capitalism well
you're right it is cronyism but what
pfizer is
what what pfizer is doing today
pfizer is getting the fda correct that
they've probably bought to say hey
can you go out there and make sure you
delay the number of losses till 2076 who
the hell is going to give a crap about
anything to do with covet 55 years from
let me make my point we'll go in 55
years from now we'll be including 75. so
then yesterday yesterday yesterday
some people said
by that yesterday some people also said
bezos just gave a hundred million
dollars to obama's foundation okay so on
the back end folks are saying well maybe
those issues that you know bezos and
amazon was facing
uh obama's gonna make a phone call to
biden to get a favor yeah it's it's
things like this where you lose trust
because manipulation takes place at the
highest level
you're a dummy if you don't sit there
and say two thousand you know what you
know a guy just sent something right now
the answer was a follow-on here's what
the guy said i want to give him credit
cause the answer was a great answer he
says he says you went away till 2076 to
uh release all the data guess what i'm
going to wait till 2076 to take the
vaccine so that's what i'm going to do
by the way
is it reasonable is it reasonable i
think it's reasonable yeah i think it's
reasonable because i want to get more
data before i take it right if you're if
you're a data person this gives more red
flags for somebody not to take to
support your cause not taking a vaccine
and you know back to this you know we're
looking at the fda is the fda here to
protect the consumer or here to protect
the government and based on what we're
saying here that's a governing entity
uh not you know that's a government
entity that's going to not protect
i agree with the overall premise all
right but i just and this might be
semantics and this might be a
nonsensical word argument but what is
described there and that happens all the
time cronyism that's actually not
capitalism what that is is corporatism
that's where the government picks
winners in certain you know functions
right where you give pfizer a
billion-dollar grant now a small company
can't come up with compete with that but
here's the here's the thing to me that's
closer to socialism than it is there's
no question of course it is but it is an
extension of capitalism because the
capitalists are using this
uh that's available to them this usage
they're using this do you think cronyism
and corporatism is an inevitable end of
capitalism
if the laws are the way they are right
now yes for example as much as i love
this phone
as much as i love this phone if you go a
little lower i said number three more
competition for business that i haven't
had for many years apple needs more
competition it concerns me that there's
not really a second competitor in
smartphones in the us right now tesla
was the best thing that happened to us
consumers they woke up the automobile
industry to improve bottling needs
competition coke and pepsi on ninety
percent of market i'll leave it there
the point is
look at this this is a concern apple
apple is this apple i don't know if this
is this ipad or no
apple apple apple apple apple apple this
is not good this is not so that's
probably that is a form of what makes
capitalism you know end up going in this
direction so yeah i don't think these
guys should be taking money from these
guys because the more why would an fda
say yes
go behind closed doors saying how much
money matter of fact can you put in
pfizer supporting fda how much money is
fizer giving to what charity or what
non-profit sure you'll see a linkage
there so this is where i get very
uncomfortable because the truth is not
coming out the person that's funding the
most money is coming on the back end
pendulum swung too far in that direction
uh
this is this is not a new thing this has
been going on for quite some time look
again i'm at harvard i'm at an opm
program owner president management this
is a three-week program where you go and
stay there with other ceos and
entrepreneurs one guy says i own
majority of the market in brazil what
the hell do i do there's this new guy
that's coming out that's kicking my ass
the other guy from another central
american country comes out and says very
easy what governor is running for
campaign for reelection give him 500 000
and tell him you'll give another half a
million dollars if he makes it
impossible for the other guy to compete
with you believe me this is what we do
all the time
this is in the open discussion
it's like a regular talk this is what
country and this was brazil i don't
remember the other guy where he was at
but the guy the guy that's working at
the front the teacher who was like the
moderator it's like well well well you
can't really do something like because
like no you can't that's right
you can do this it reminds me of rodney
dangerfield in that in that old uh back
to school where he goes back to school
and he's sitting there and they're
learning business and he keeps scoffing
they're like you think you know
something about business he goes yeah
you didn't even tell you throwing any
bribes for the teamsters they're gonna
shut the union down the first day unless
you grease the pipes and he does this
whole thing it's a great scene but when
you talk about when people triple lindy
one of two classic movies of all time
dangerous when people talk about the
quote-unquote illuminati and this like
crazy cabals and stuff like that that's
what they're talking about they're
talking about the bilderbergs and and
the world economic forum where all these
incredibly powerful people and all these
incredibly powerful influential
positions get together and they make
these back room deals like that we don't
have access to that we don't have access
to that sort of power by the way by the
way i don't mind it if it happens in
free market i mind it if you lean on the
government for example this lady that
they're talking about making the
treasury for uh biden right what's
what's her name tyler uh uh uh
uh almost say that again omar have a
hard time saying her name omarava
omarava right so a video circulates
among what she just recently said so
she's at the court ted cruz has called
on a route have you guys seen this back
in fourth or not have you seen ted cruz
and her going back and forth or no have
you seen it have you had a chance to see
this or not okay if it's c-span it's
worthy of seeing this
uh if it's c-span it's worthy of seeing
this take a look at it and see if it's
out there or not so this lady flat out
says uh you said omarava oh how do you
spell it s-a-u-l-e o-m-a
u-l-e
o-m-a-r-o-v-a
to eliminate the fed i said no way let
me hear this okay good for you joe and
it was like yeah eliminate the fed and
all private banking
oh
you guys have you guys actually seen
this or not on uh c-span okay
omarova oh man if it's not on c-span we
obviously cannot watch it because of uh
uh what happens okay i don't know if
it's there or not anyways he calls her
out she used to be uh she's born and
raised in russia full-on communist okay
and she's coming in and she
says well yeah i used to be a communist
says you don't stay as a member you kind
of grow out of being a communist that's
her answer she just kind of nonchalant
talks about it play the video i just
sent you by the way tyler the one i uh
by the way obama said the same thing in
his book he did but watch this just
let's not interrupt let her say what she
says in an interview press play here's
what she has to say this would be
actually
the full transition in other words there
will be no more private uh bank deposit
accounts and all of the deposit accounts
will be held directly at the fed
and there are very interesting
implications uh from that thought
experiment for example with uh the much
more direct and proactive tools of
monetary policy like helicopter money
which is uh
you know considered radical primarily
because uh economists really do not know
how to manage the issue of what will
happen
in the inflationary environment when the
central bank needs to contract the
supply of money how is it
politically feasible for the central
bank to effectively take money away
from uh people's account
people's accounts let me play the last
10 seconds one more time folks i want
you to listen to this one more time this
is who may end up getting elected well
listen press play yeah stop everything
the supply of money how is it
politically feasible for the central
bank to effectively take money away
from uh people's accounts ouch people's
accounts that's her words naturally
what's she saying
so you asked the question you said you
know how these guys get together the
powerful people behind closed doors and
the broker deals all that stuff i don't
mind that as long as the government's
not involved i have zero problem with
that because if i can do a better job
persuading him to broker the deal with
me versus him i'm good because it's
forced
because because i can screw it up with
him well he'll go with him but if i'm
dealing with the government if i screwed
up with him
there is no there's no choice no so
these guys when they're thinking central
back the regular the audience sees this
like if you said this to the because the
government became a competitor the
government became a competitor you know
that's just communism with a lot of that
that's just comments of course that is
so again the concept goes back to go to
dmv ask for good service see what they
give you
what's the alternative there's not
another dmv there is not another dmv so
if we no longer have b of a chase ice to
bank would be a vague guess what i did i
went to wamu obama was crushing it i've
been with wamu and chase for god knows
how many years now if wamu doesn't take
care you got wells fargo wells carter
you got this you got that so we switched
one of our business banks for uh the
company because the new bank was better
for us and the other bank you know how
much money they lost in deposits 100
million dollars of deposits they lost
but if i don't have that choice where i
can only go to the central bank you are
screwed yeah pbd it's it's worse than
that even because think about what we
just talked about they're regulating a
medicine now they have access to your
funds
and they say unless you get what we want
you unless you put what we want in your
body we're not going to give you access
to your money yeah well that's why uh
biden wanted to expand the uh irs
enforcement to make sure that anything
that you
bring in over 600 is monitored therefore
if you're not paying taxes on it they
can come after you say hey we saw that
you had a bunch of deposits 600 bucks
700 bucks 800 bucks you never filed tax
on it because you're a waiter because
you work on tips but you're a cash money
guy you have a you have a you know you
sell a lot in the corner and you have
your work running cash bid you're
depositing over 6 700 bucks a day now
you have to file taxes on it and they're
forcing that regulation appropriately
we're never going to raise taxes on on
the middle class no no no no no no no no
but i had to realize that three trillion
dollar plan was going to pay and that
was something that they were proposing
and but they realized that it was a
logistical nightmare and the banks are
like dude we're not trying to monitor
every six hundred dollars and they
raised obviously ten thousand dollars is
the traditional number for these types
of things but
it just goes to show that
sometimes bad ideas can sort of
percolate and if there's not people
being like
what's happening what's going on here
you know they could somehow get
implemented so someone like this that
clearly we're like what's this lady's
deal what's this
taking money from people's account what
is this idea going on here if there's
not backlash or it's not people raising
their hands like literally verbally
protesting
someone like this can come it's a great
point like gizlane maxwell trial is
going on right now and nobody even knows
everybody knows everything that's
happening with the kyle rittenhouse
child every second of everything you
know and there was some good theater
there those two prosecutors were
all-time morons with you know what they
tried is your account four doors more
[ __ ] sir yeah i'm a teenager what's
one of it bro i'm a teenager with a
social media account like it was it was
a remarkably bad job that they did but
just laying maxwell if everybody knows
who she's laying max was she was the
number two jeffrey epstein the number
two the number two you know she was the
gopher man and
we all we all remember what jeffrey
epstein had his hands in and all of
those people that he was just right up
is that on the news at all where's the
coverage
so i haven't heard about it what type of
social engineering is going on what type
of manipulation is going on that we
don't know that they're trying to
centralize our money underneath them
they're trying to control our medicine
they're trying to control our
information pat just read an article
before where they slipped in propaganda
in an article you know which is safe and
it's safe and available guys like okay
thanks buddy at what point are we like
gonna as people stand up and like be
like all right enough's enough so i had
i had an fbi agent this last week uh i
don't know what his name was was he fbi
was he uh jim clementi jim clemente
really enjoyed the interview phenomenal
teacher of what they do he was an fbi
agent for 20-something years his brother
is an fbi agent as well so both are fbi
agents and then
his other brother peter does something
else he's private equity and they
started a company together and they're
doing good so here's what i did i uh
played a clip of uh
rand paul and fauci
because what this guy does for a living
is he sees what's the word he used he
his deception so his job is to see
deception okay he's the fbi agent like
if somebody's lying as somebody's lying
deception so i said you know i want i
want to do
let's profile somebody if it's okay with
you let's profile somebody and we play
this clip now know that he is and
complete
not a fan of former administration okay
so i wanted to have trump's
uh zero like zero okay okay yeah zero so
he is a supporter of the current
administration more than the prior
administration and i said i want to kind
of profile and kind of get your feeling
on this and tell me if you believe fouch
is telling the truth or where he stands
with this can you play this clip just
play the clip let's watch for first four
minutes of it and maybe if you know how
to do the speed do me a favor click on
that do you know what that okay and can
you guys do 1.5 go to 1.5 not 2.0 1.5
because they all talk slow
so press play and let's let
ren make his argument first and then
when it comes to tony's answer slow it
down to 1.0 to really get the feeling of
three weeks have you guys seen this or
not this is from three weeks ago you've
not seen this this is not i have not
okay open it up because you're about to
be blown away yeah right
their own reality okay
click on this and just listen i don't
expect you today to admit that you
approved of nih funding for gain and
function research and wuhan but your
repeated denials of warren thin and a
majority of americans frankly don't
believe you even the nih now admits that
eco-health alliance did perform
experiments in muhammad that created
viruses not found
found in nature that actually did gain
in lethality the facts are clear the nih
did fund gain of function research in
wuhan despite your protestations he
denied all you want but even the chinese
authors of the paper in their paper
admit that viruses not found in nature
were created and yes they gained in
infectivity your persistent denials
though are not simply a stain on your
reputation but are clear and present
danger to the country and to the world
the world as professor kevin svelt of
mit has written gain of function
research looks like a gamble that
civilization can't afford to risk and
yet here we are again with you steadfast
in your denials why does it matter
because gain of function research with
laboratory created viruses not found in
nature could cause a pandemic even worse
the next time we're suffering today from
one that has a mortality of
approximately one percent they're
experimenting with viruses that have
mortalities of between 15 and 50 percent
yes our civilization could be at risk
for one of these viruses
experiments that combine unknown viruses
with known pandemic causing viruses are
incredibly risky experiments that
combine unknown viruses with
coronaviruses that have as much as 50
mortality could endanger civilization as
we know it and here you sit
unwilling to accept any responsibility
for the current pandemic and unwilling
to take any steps to prevent gain of
function research from possibly
unleashing an even more deadly virus you
mislead the public by saying that the
published viruses could not be coveted
well exactly no one is alleging that no
one is alleging that the published
viruses by the chinese are covered what
we are saying is that this was risky
type of research gain of function
research it was risky to share this with
the with the chinese and that coveted
may have been created from
the chinese are going to reveal the
virus if it came from their lab
you know that but you continue to
mislead you continue to support nih
money going to wuhan you can simply say
you trust the chinese scientist you
appear to have learned nothing from this
pandemic
will you today finally take some
responsibility for funding to function
research and move on pause it pause it
pause it first
pause it first now go to speed and i
just watch body language and listen
if you're telling the truth you're going
to know you don't have to
go press play with two masks in the
background he's a messed up extremely
safe senator with all due respect i
disagree with so many of the things that
you've said
again first of all gain of function
is a very nebulous term
we have spent not
us but outside bodies a considerable
amount of effort
to give a more precise definition to the
entity
of research that is of concern
that might lead to a dangerous situation
you think you are aware of that
that is called p3 co we're aware that
you deleted gain of function from the
nih website well i can get back to that
in a moment if we have time
but let's get back to the operating
framework and guidewells of which we
operate under bad actors you have
ignored them
the guidelines are very very clear
that you have to be dealing with a
pathogen that clearly is shown and very
likely
to be highly transmissible in an
uncontrollable way
in humans and to have a high degree of
morbidity and mortality and that you do
experiments to enhance
that hence the word e p p p
enhanced pathogens of potentia
eco health alliance took the virus
and combined it with wiv 1 and caused a
recombinant virus that doesn't exist in
nature and it made my sicker mice that
had humanized cells you're saying that
that's not gain of function research
according to the framework and
guidelines
so what you're doing is defining a weigh
gain of function you're simply saying it
doesn't exist because you changed the
definition on the nih website this is
terrible and you're you're completely
trying to escape the idea that we should
do something about trying to prevent a
pandemic from he's a doctor for
now points towards this coming from the
lab and what you've done is change the
definition on your website to try to
cover your ass basically that's what
you've done you've changed the website
to try to have a new definition that
doesn't include the risky research
that's going on until you admit that
it's risky we're not going to get
anywhere you have to admit that this
research was risky the nih has now
rebuked them your own agency has rebuked
them
but the thing is is you're still
unwilling to admit that they gained in
function when they say they became
sicker they gained in lethality it's a
new virus that's not gain of function
watch what happens according to the
definition that is currently operable
you know senator
let's make it clear
people who are listening
the current definition
was done over a two to three year period
by outside bodies including the nsa
speeded up through one point five
conferences by the national academy of
science engineering medicine on december
2014 march 2016. we commissioned
external risk benefit assessment and
then on january of 2017 the office of
science and technology policy of the
white house issued the current policy
and coincidentally
on the same day the nih said that yes
there was a gain of function in wuhan
the same day the definition appeared the
new definition
was going to move on until you accept it
until you expect accept responsibility
we're not going to get anywhere close to
trying to prevent another live league of
this dangerous sort of experiment you
won't know that it's dangerous and for
that lack of judgment i think it's time
that you resign thank you senator paul i
would like um to give the time to doctor
there were so many things that are
egregious misrepresentation here madam
chair that i don't think i'd be able to
refute all of them but just a couple of
them for the lessons to hear for you has
said that i'm unwilling to take any
responsibility for the current pandemic
i have no responsibility for the current
pandemic the current pandemic okay
number two you said the overwhelming
amount of evidence indicates that's a
lab leak i believe most card carrying
viral phylogenists and molecular
virologists would disagree with you that
is much more likely even though we leave
open all possibilities it's much more
likely this was a natural occurrence
third you say we've contested 80 000
animals and no animals have been found
with hope all the time
you made a statement just a moment ago
that's completely incorrect where you
say we continue to support research at
the wuhan institute of virology in
august
no no your statement says quote i wrote
it down as you were writing you
continued to support research at the
wuhan institute of arizona a month ago
and said you still trust the chinese
scientists and you still support the
research over there you said it a month
ago i have allowed dr fauci to respond
you've had your time i'm going to give
him he's going to be dishonest he ought
to be jealous senator paul we will allow
dr fatchi to respond after you've given
accusations like that dr fauci well i
don't have any more to say except to say
that as usual and i i have a great
respect for this body of the senate and
it makes me very uncomfortable to have
to say something but he is egregiously
incorrect in what he says thank you
history will figure that out on its own
turn to senator hassan thank you okay so
now here's the question
what's that oh
gonna close that buddy do you think that
thing could lift my fat ass
i want one of those
but but but listening to what just
happened right there do you believe
fauci for what he said do you believe
him
it's hard for me man because i hate that
man with every fiber in my being sorry
why though why is that though why
because i think he's i think that there
is so much evidence
to show that he has lied
in so many different ways at so many
different varying stages that once you
lie in a situation like this and i and
there's too many people out there that
that
brush it off and say well politicians
lie one he's not a politician he's not
supposed to be anyway he is but he's not
supposed to be and two in a situation
like this if you lie to cover your ass
once i can never trust you again you're
just going to cover your ass cover your
ass cover your ass and if your job is
more important to you than your your
neighbors your countrymen if you've been
willing to watch what's happened to your
country for the last 20 months just to
save your own ass come on man i got
nothing for you bro and that's that's
not even getting into the more
conspiratorial stuff with the beagles
and everything like that you know you
know what's very weird to me
how the hell have we not started an
investigation on china how are we not
going after the why is it so
uncomfortable to say you know there
could possibly be so so where i'm going
with that is if we're uncomfortable with
that then there's something that's being
hidden if we are so protective of not
wanting to go after somebody that cannot
stand what we stand for the china cannot
stand what we stand for and after all
the tariffs then all of a sudden we have
a pandemic to get rid of a guy you can't
stand because he figured out a way how
to make your life a living health
through the tariffs and we can't
investigate that even this is what jon
stewart asked on stephen colbert if we
can't investigate it that that's a
little bit too uh uh uncomfortable what
did the fbi agent say about that
conversation the fbi fbi agent said uh
his answer was david remind me what he
said he said i i don't have enough
information to make uh statements i
don't know uh everything about this i
said you know what since you run a
podcast i'd love to see you take an
extensive because there's billions of
people worldwide that would want to know
if you believe the situation or not
because that's your expertise so he said
well maybe we're going to do it on the
podcast so we'll see if they're going to
do it or not well would you agree these
types of conversations should be
consistent and
into perpetuity until some sort of like
i wish there was some sort of
fact-checking that was going on there
because i didn't see a lot of
quivering or deflecting from fouchy i'm
not a huge fouchy fan but i'm not like
gerard i don't hate fauci i think he's
put in a difficult situation has he lied
has he
i don't know i'm not going to be like
this is the way it is i don't know okay
i do appreciate the fact that rand paul
is grilling him and holding him to
account
uh
look i don't also he's 80 freaking years
old he doesn't need this job he's the
most highest paid person in the
government and why is he still doing it
that's okay that's a that's a very good
question i don't know i don't have that
answer i don't pretend no lying or he's
bad at his job yeah so it's one of two
really bad options you're either really
bad at what you're doing or you're like
the answer is i don't know we i that's
why i appreciate what what rand paul is
doing as an annoying it is for fouchy
he's holding him to account is there
anybody in this room or watching right
now anybody serious question that thinks
that we've been told the truth as they
know it the whole time of course not
no i don't but also something that we
but if they lie to you this
why do you think they would stop lying
all of a sudden well then why believe
any politician ever or anything
or any spokesperson
exactly so it's like everyone's lying
every
everyone lies every single day whether
it's a white lie or a full-on bold lie
it's a d these lies don't shut down most
lies don't shut down the world though i
will say one thing when this thing
happened did you think they actually
knew what was going to occur
meaning when fauci got the news of this
or any of these people
it would use a mask don't use a mask
it's not coming from muhammad it is
coming from one it came from a bad it's
not from a badass they knew immediately
it didn't come from a damn bat i think
that that was nonsensical from the jump
was it though like a guy ate a bat
and then the world got sick was a
nonsense i mean that was a nonsensical
thing from the beginning
i mean it was just insane oh by the way
the bat just happens to be
uh you know
well two and a half
who did you ask you asked that we were
in an interview once you asked the guy
how come how come they don't break rank
how come they don't because no one's
pressing them they no one's pressing
them
how did you get the mafia guys to turn
you threatened him with 100 years
you pressed him
flip on his buddies what i don't get is
that we are what one-third of the
population of china one-third of the
population of india but yet we lead the
world
in covet
19 infections because we're fat and
unhealthy
also because we're accurately reporting
where i don't think these other
countries are yeah that's that's another
thing too as well so i you know it's uh
there's a profit incentive to be covered
positive don't forget that correct you
could have had the flu you could have
all these things it was thousand dollars
if you were back to following the money
back back why people are lying you
follow the money trail the other aspect
too is if we do keep
digging up on china i think it starts
another war i mean this is a some form
of war right here it's a biological war
then there's an economic war and then
they're sending this supersonic missile
that nobody ever caught on radar that
could trigger so many different
events if we're boldly pointing a finger
at china it can drastically affect
america i mean look at right now
everybody's being affected by the supply
chain and things coming from china over
to america i did i did a i did a show
where uh i just randomly pulled things
from my kids uh uh toys pokemon cards
you know star wars lightsabers
the whole thing i had i brought it to
the office 10 of the things all made in
china sure this is scary part
matt
i'm at the point who cares we're the
united freaking states of america china
needs us we don't need you sure they
want to play these games usa baby we
retract yeah we retract access to our
market they want to do what they want to
do god bless xi jinping
for years has had no problem
agitating and escalating with us and all
of a sudden the western world is
supposed to be like well go oh god we go
for midweek
to hell with them yeah to hell with them
circle the wagons get our industries
going get our people working for our
people bring pharmaceuticals back here
bring manufacturing back back here okay
all right and enough they want to play
their games and we're just supposed to
be like oh god what oh they're very very
strong they're very powerful who are we
yeah
we forgot who we are in this country man
to bring the manufacturing from china
into let's say mexico
india pat loves india i'm sure india
would love a couple trillion dollars i
think the philippines would love some of
those jobs come on all of which we're
supposed we're supposed to be afraid
yeah get out of here they want the smoke
back-to-back world war champs buddy
yeah i i well you lost me at the last
sentence yeah i agreed with you until
then then when you start talking like
you've done have you run back palace on
your hand run
when you're rooting for a world war
that's totally i'm not rooting for a
world war what i'm saying is that they
want it we're not backing down enough
retreating that type of rhetoric is is
it listen we do not want another cold
war with china we've had that with
russia i don't think that works out with
anybody uh we do need to have dialogue
you don't think the cold war worked out
for the united states of america yeah
well other than the fact that we almost
got nuked i think it did work out no but
that's the whole point of uh
live in fear of an aggressor i'm not
saying that we should they're the
aggressor right now they're not they're
not retracting xi jinping's not saying
well god forbid we don't want a war
let's all live no he's not he's like our
times now to hell with them and now
we're just supposed to be like well it's
their time it's their time god forbid we
do anything that's some never change
neville chamberlain [ __ ] when a bully
gets empowered he doesn't all of a
sudden become enlightened and go you
know what yeah let's let's back more and
more and more
that's have you ever seen any of these
uh chinese uh combat movies uh on
netflix have you ever stumbled across
some of those new chinese rambo yeah
they're like they're like promoting
their military a lot you know how strong
the military is and their naval forces
and their special forces it's
interesting they've been doing that
lately
i don't know man you guys are going to
be able to stack up in the united states
marine baby come get some
look do i want one of course i don't
want war of course not but at the same
time i'm sick of us let me let me let me
put it to you this way here's here's a
you and i had a conversation together
about uh uh mafia states and i said i
want to know
where the issue was and you said well
everything the buck stops you know with
me et cetera so we want to know and we
found out a lot right in the last four
weeks okay
now if we find out what happened then
what can we do
the next time around we make adjustments
that's all i care about right
it's
we find out what took place so the next
time we're going through this we make
better decisions and better choices
knowing who does better under pressure
who's more for i'm going to come through
and deliver on my promises
i i i want to know what the hell
happened with colbit because the last
here's here's what we still don't know
these guys are time until 2076 we can't
investigate what happened with the
pfizer okay we're not going to know what
happened with kids
we you and i have kids we're not going
to know what happened with kids
for 20 or 30 years you're not going to
know that we have no clue what's going
to happen so what those kids got to go
do what they got to do because somebody
wanted to play the game that they played
yeah it doesn't sit well with me so now
here's the part we're not pansies we're
not softies we're not like helpless to
say oh my gosh this is not fair no all
i'm saying is i want to know what the
hell happened that's all i care about if
they were involved in this fauci has got
to want to know as much as anybody else
wants to know rather than them saying no
it wasn't china now how do you know it
wasn't china
how do you know it's not china that's
the problem so if if he says well it's
david
no no no no it's not david let's not
investigate david david didn't do it
david's not going with the onion how do
you know it's not david uh it's a little
weird there that you're so protective of
david but you're okay if i go to tyler
and mata yeah yeah investigate but no no
no no no david didn't do it
how are you so certain yeah so that is a
very very weird situation for me i'm not
saying it is or it's not but it's very
weird where you're all of a sudden
that's protective do they know something
about you that the rest of the world
doesn't know is there something that if
we would have found out about you that
you're gonna flip out i don't know is
there a reason why all these interviews
that was done with the judy mykovitz got
cancelled is there a reason why so many
people want to hide anything that's
written about you is there a reason why
robert f kennedy the top environmental
attorney in america that is rfk's son
writes a book about you that just came
out as a top 10 book on amazon why are
so many people wanting to find out more
about you why don't people trust you
what what caused people to not trust you
what's going on here what what is
that that's where i want to know certain
jobs you shouldn't take without knowing
the heat that comes with it just don't
take it don't say i want to be a c-suite
oh really so you are now a c-suite but
you're [ __ ] bricks about being a
c-suite don't freaking be a c-suite go
be a manager don't be a c-suite i want
to be a salesperson oh really you're a
salesperson but every month you're
asking for in advance against your
commission because you're broke because
you can't sell go back and be an
employee you want to be this person
that's going to be on it for the entire
time during the time like this all the
pressure is on you so i just want to get
to the bottom and see what happened and
whoever that screwed it up you got to be
held accountable whoever did the right
thing we got to turn them into hero
history books has to
turn the people that did the right thing
into a hero and if it's him let's do it
if we find out everything and he is
truly right i want this guy to have the
most ridiculous retirement celebration
people showing up because he did the
right thing but if he's not
and you were dividing america and
hurting us you got to go to jail buddy
100 percent you got to go pay the price
for it so is the organization that
should be investigating china and and to
your point why don't we hear about
that more often like is there
who who is the organ is not the who is
it the united states is it the world
health organization who is it that
should in fact be
investigating china in this combination
and why isn't it in the head you know
front page news every single day
national security advisers should be in
the cia
beyond it yeah but like is there is
there a centralized power that should be
doing this is the world involved
there's a there's quite a few
organizations that could do this but
there's also a reason why maybe they're
not doing this first of all if they did
decide to do this you don't think behind
closed doors they're sitting there
saying hey two thousand dollar
containers for twenty five thousand
we're gonna have a fine christmas in
china you guys are not gonna have a good
christmas because we're making a gift
here in the toys here and all we have to
do is drive it over you guys need a ship
we don't need a ship we're fine you
wanna do anything to us go right ahead
the world has empowered them so much
that they have so much leverage that
everybody's walking on eggshells making
sure
they don't screw up because they own
manufacturing they own the chips they
own everything
so many pharmaceuticals pfizer 80
you can't go on but percentage of acs
they make there's so many different
things they have control over this is
the world's fault this is this is
america's fault on the policies of how
they negotiated with china when they
were a small little not not a
population-wise but they were not a
superpower to not being who they are and
it's being ran by a guy like him who
can't stand america who can't stand rich
people who it has to be all about him
yeah
the world paid a price for it america
led the way because america is the
leader of the free world you made them
stronger now you're going to pay a price
for it a lot of people made themselves
very very rich in those deals and they
enriched themselves by selling out their
company listen say you got say you got
five sales people in your organization
one guy is an absolute um
dirt bag okay
does shady business
steals all this stuff
if you
keep making him the hero over and over
and over and over and over again a year
two years three years five years from
now your company goes on because of him
it's not his fault it's your fault
it's your lack of paranoia where you
empowered the wrong person you're paying
a price price for it you shouldn't have
been naive america became naive and they
empowered a communistic region what are
you doing empowering that country you
could have gone to india you could have
gone to so many different places to
empower why are you empowering somebody
whose philosophies are completely
opposing of our philosophies i don't
understand this if you're gonna empower
somebody we should at least have similar
values and principles that we don't have
to have the same religion
you can be a buddhist you can be a
seventh day you can be a catholic you
can be a muslim you can't but if we both
have similar values and principles that
we follow by we ought to do business
together do you realize how completely
opposite communism and capitalism is
sure
sweatshops they got over there people
are working for two three cents at that
time or down you half a dollar 50 cents
an hour they're this they're working
like they're destroying these people but
no let's keep producing business over
there because it's cheaper yeah that was
our friend enos cantor basically called
that out yeah and and by the way he's
got a good point and you know lebron
wasn't too happy about it he was asking
about a matter of fact let's get right
into that story in his canter rips
disgusting lebron's
uh james over nike connection this is a
washington examiner story he continued
his war against nike on thursday saying
sparring no words while ripping into
lebron james cantor who has previously
accused nike of telling a total lie
about china's alleged use of slave labor
to produce its products aimed this round
at nike's biggest star money over morals
for the king the celtics center tweeted
sad and disgusting how these athletes
pretend
they care about social justice they
really do shut up and dribble when big
boss says so do you educate yours did
you educate yourself about the slave
labor and made your shoes uh or is that
not part of your research james refused
to offer his own thoughts about china's
political policies instead claiming he
had to conduct more research so i mean
they're going back and forth here and
his cantor's not going to slow down but
lebron what he said in the interview he
says
hey he walked through the hallway he
could have stopped and talked to me but
he didn't do anything he's trying to
make his name like he's trying to say
like he's trying to make his name off me
so hey you had the opportunity to face
me and you didn't which by the way i
agree with lebron
why don't you go deal with them directly
if you did walk into the hallway with
them now if lebron's lying which i don't
think he is
he's trying to build himself up enes is
going to come back because i never walk
past this guy okay but if ennis now
comes out and says hey i'm willing to do
a live with you let's talk about it if
venice says let's have a meeting and
talk about this now if he wants to kind
of come back at it but
yeah i mean he's right because look what
happened lebron tweeted about kyle
rittenhouse just a couple weeks ago and
he got destroyed for it last week or a
week and a half ago sure but a guy comes
in and drives through a community in
wisconsin kills five people
hospitalizes 40 people where is a story
about that what's worse of a story it's
a horrible story horrible story kids
this is like what are you doing
well you you you have you watched a
video of course
did you see the car plummeting or like
going over bodies and it's bumping up
and i'm surprised the kids even got up
because some of them got up like you
just got rant over and he was out on on
uh bail bail thousand dollar bail for he
was running from a domestic dispute he
tried to run his wife over earlier in
the morning like his pregnant or his
pregnant girlfriend he tried to run her
over with his car earlier
we're kind of all over the place in this
story but you know how we talked about
athletes have to invent them reinvent
themselves have to have a second act
clearly innes cantor is
positioning himself for something bigger
than basketball when his career is said
and done now he's sort of more of a
backup he's the backup center on the
celtics now he's been on five teams in
as many years this is not new though i
don't think no exactly he went after
erdogan he went back to one it started
with afraid of exactly not afraid of air
to one you're not afraid of lebron james
and he can't go back to turkey they've
revoked his visa or his passport he
can't go back there he's been he's been
talking about free tibet he's obviously
calling out the uyghurs that is going on
in china yeah this is something that
he's doing consistently and he looks at
lebron and he's got
on the court and off the court beef with
lebron they've had some issues um but
the nba needs someone like
um innis cantor to sort of
be the thorn in people's side lebron's
getting challenged if you have to i mean
lebron's had a rough week they came back
after being out for a month
injury now this insult he got he got
suspended you know how much he got
suspended for you know how much money
he's losing for that one game as a
steward yeah isaiah stewart he's losing
um what does it say here probably 500
grand or something yeah like 300 grand
for for the one game the other guy who
has never even heard his name before
he's losing uh 45 grand out two games
um lebron's had a rough week but i hope
he can recover
yeah i think he's gonna be i think he's
going to be all right
for face in the league to be that way
oh this is the thing right like do you
expect anything
but uh i do actually look a little bit
deeper than you know who
skip bail shannon shannon sharp says on
on skip and shannon that lebron can't
ever come out and say he's friends with
louis farrakhan all right he he's
reading malcolm x he's reading not that
this is bad this is good stuff to read
but he he
uses nation of islam
language when he talks he talks about i
stand up for my people the there's a
there's this weird la vibe where there's
this this nouveau
kind of um
like nationalism that's coming out where
this type of rhetoric becomes incredibly
incredibly
familiar to people that have heard this
before i think and this is just pure
speculation but this is a podcast and i
can speculate i think that there are
some influences that are that are pretty
extreme that have found their way into
lebron's life i think that there's a lot
of influences especially within the
wealthy black community right now that
are
nation of islam slash marxist
in nature and it's becoming this this
this um cultural
epicenter where they've got these like
rich attractive charismatic cultural
icons within the black community
specifically and that's where there's
gonna trickle down they're gonna divulge
the marxist and the nationalist rhetoric
and it's you're hearing it more and more
and if you know what you're listening
for it's pretty obvious so i i don't
know i think for someone like ennis
cantor here's some something like that
he's a pretty well-read guy and he's
like this this is this is [ __ ] this
guy's full of it this this guy's spewing
nonsense and he wants to take him to the
task about it
well as i always tell you gerard there's
you got you got globalists
and you got you got nationalists
federalists over here
and uh you got to pick a side good job
okay hey kai you want to come and tell
us what the merch drop you want to do
here oh tell us what this merch dropped
this guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
so what's the merch we got
let's go out here
i am so curious to know how many this is
going to be this guy's wearing the
shirts
guys wearing the shirt
you got to get the autograph i'm gonna
get my autograph bro that's insanity
let's go at him
at least your name made it on his shirt
you know this is pretty good
yeah maybe they'll make some songs about
you let's go
let's go
say that again you got one here tell us
adam wanted merch so we made him some
merch now he can be represented
so tell us
about what you got today only we have 20
off flat off the store the whole store
for an early black friday offer so uh so
people can go ahead to vt merch and
they'll also find the let's go adam
shirts where they can support it we have
new hats and we have a bunch of other
stuff some mugs and
some stuff up there so they can go to
vtmerch.com okay so you're doing what
you're also doing if you spend over 50
years over over 50 they get free
shipping and then uh if they spend over
40 they get to 20 tell us about these
hats as well these hats are imperial
hats uh they're more of a breathable
flex kind of
material where they can definitely more
durable for any sporting events or if
you're outside kind of an active fit on
that okay all good and for those of you
guys that love adam and you want to buy
that shirt there's only a hundred of
them so first hundred dollars
put the link below you'll get it but
after 100 it sells out so anyways hey uh
we will let you know i think are we
scheduled for thursday we don't know yet
but we will let you know we'll do a
podcast on thursday or not we may do an
emergency podcast in the next
uh uh i don't know maybe next uh it
could be tomorrow could be the next day
stay tuned we'll text when we do an
emergency podcast it's gonna be pretty
big announcements about mafia states if
we're ready if we're not it looks
incredible by the way i don't want to
get anybody scared it's going to be it's
going to be insane well sammy did you
guarantee that it would be out by the
end of the year so we got to now see
whether we're going to do that or not
anyways hey if we don't do this happy
thanksgiving to you if we do we'll see
you next couple days take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you